-Welcome back, guys.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since "The Bachelorette"
season 17 was just announced,
I sent out the hashtag
#WhyImSingle.
And I asked you guys
to tweet out
a funny, weird or embarrassing
reason you're single.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
I appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#WhyImSingle responses
from you guys.
This first one is
from @freak00music.
-Hmm, 00.
-They say, "I was on my lunch
break with one of my colleagues
who I had a crush on.
In the middle of
our conversation,
he raised his hand
and I went in for a high-five.
Turns out he was
just waving to his friend
who had walked into the room."
[ Applause ]
-Wow. Uh-oh.
-This one is
from @gilliannot123.
She says, "My date pronounced
the L in salmon."
And I said out loud,
'Well, you're not the one.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good for you.
"A sal-mon for one, please."
-"Okay, I'm gone."
-"Alright."
This one is
from @caitlincarrickm.
She says, "I'm single because I
get mad at people in real life
for things they did
in my dreams."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-I like that.
[ Laughs ]
This one is from @marisarosie22.
She says,
"I tried flirting with a guy
by saying his smile is great.
He says he gets it from his mom.
I replied,
'Your mom must be hot then.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's not good.
-I guess.
-That's not good.
That's not good.
-"I'm mad at you
for my dreams still."
-This one's
from @jakewilliamsart.
He says,
"I think Doritos are too sharp,
so I bite off all the corners
first before I eat them.
I call them Rounditos."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Rounditos?
-I do the same thing.
-You do the same thing?
-Yeah, yeah.
-They're not called Doritos
because they're a triangle.
-They're not called Doritos.
They're called doe-ritos.
[ Laughter ]
-Doe-ritos?
-Doe-ritos.
[ Laughter ]
-They're not called doe-ritos.
-Yes, they are.
-I thought
they were called door-itos
'cause you can make
a tiny door out of them.
[ Laughter ]
-I say it like "dur-itos."
Like, D-U-R.
-You say da-ritos.
-No, I say doe-ritos.
-Doe-ritos?
-Maybe that will be
your side dish.
-I think you're putting
too much work into that.
-Hey, just a little emphasis,
man.
[ Laughter ]
-I call them
[Spanish accent] Doritos.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go.
Wow! For the win.
-[ Normal voice ] Interesting.
-Right.
-Wow!
-This one's from @joannnj1.
She says, "The last time
I had a guy over,
I showed him my sculptures
I made from red
Mini Babybel cheese wax.
He didn't come over again."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know that little --
I like that.
-Yeah.
-You know, I know these are --
-She's not wasting.
-I know that these are
like "why you're single,"
but it also shows
why you're interesting.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it would be fun
if we maybe
had a little "Love Connection"
from one of these.
-Oh, nice.
-These are all single people,
apparently.
[ Laughter ]
-Apparently.
-Maybe they're dating now.
This was back
when they were single.
This one is from @cyndianaj.
She says, "I'm single because I
take my superhero action figures
to the theater
for Marvel and DC movies
so they can watch themselves
on the big screen."
[ Applause ]
-Aww!
-Come on!
-Come on.
"Here you go. That's you."
-"There you go. Look at you."
-"Look how big you are."
[ Laughter ]
"Ooh, you just punched him!"
-This one is
from @kamie92643518.
She says, "My ex and I did
laundry together and we broke up
because he couldn't admit
that my way of folding
towels and sheets
was the correct way."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
Sal-mon!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's rough.
-There's still no way
to fold a fitted sheet.
It's just impossible.
-No, I throw them away.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not saying you do that.
-Use them once and then when I'm
done, I throw them away, yeah.
I don't want to
bother with that garbage.
[ Laughter ]
Life's too short, my man.
-This one is
from @barbrastreilamb.
-Oh, nice, nice.
Barbra Streilamb.
-Yeah. For a second,
you were like, "What?"
-"What, Barbra Streisand?"
-Barbra Streilamb.
-Straylamb.
-I like Barbra Streilamb.
-Huge fan.
-She says --
[ Laughs ]
Oh, yeah, this one's funny.
She says,
"I have various pillows
with actors' faces on them.
My favorite two
are of Danny DeVito."
Sent a picture.
Look. There she is.
-Aww!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Johnny Depp.
-And Johnny Depp behind her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
This last one is
from @interludej.
That was Tariq's first rap name.
[ Laughter ]
He says, "I prefer
to eat SpaghettiOs cold,
right out of the can."
-Oh!
-Yeah.
There you have it. Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.